para desenvolver novos olhares é preciso
fechar os olhos fechar os olhos
a gente poder perceber o que acontece
a gente que ao mesmo tempo tem um monte
de coisa acontecendo fora
tem um monte de coisa acontecendo dentro
e eu queria convidar você já que teve um
palestrante que teve essa coragem eu
queria convidar vocês também para fechar
os olhos e quando vocês fecharem os
olhos começa a nomear quais são as
sensações corporais que vocês estão
sentindo agora quais são os sentimentos
que vocês estão sentindo agora que tipo
de pensamento você tá tendo tipo de
imagem emergindo nessa na sua mente
agora
agora com os olhos fechados eu queria
pedir para vocês continuarem sentados
mas agora se ajustar
colocou-se ficar numa posição ereta
colocar os dois pés no chão
sentia a sola dos seus pés
senti a palma das suas mãos sentir você
ea superfície do seu corpo da parte de
trás do seu corpo sentado na cadeira
queria pedir para vocês trazerem uma
memória de um momento onde você se
sentiu pleno na sua vida onde você se
sentiu completo quando você se sentiu
integrado
se você puder colher essa memória uma
parte do seu corpo e deixar expandir e
agora dá uma inspiração profunda uma
respiração diafragmática que parece que
enche o seu abdome
respirando abrindo os olhos
quem mudou de estado da primeira vez que
fechou os olhos e prestar atenção nas
sensações pela segunda vez
bastante gente que acontece o que eu
acabei de fazer com você está
acontecendo o tempo todo com a gente
toda vez que a realidade emerge a gente
escolhe uma resposta
e porque a gente tem porque o nosso
sistema nervoso o nosso cérebro olímpico
a forma com as crenças que a gente
desenvolve para o mundo elas borrão a
forma como a gente interpreta a
realidade é como se a realidade
emergisse momento o momento com toda sua
beleza ea gente borracha porque a gente
carrega o passado para interpretar o que
está acontecendo no futuro e é isso que
eu queria por isso eu digo que a gente
precisa fechar os olhos a gente precisa
se diz condicionar a gente precisa se
desabituaram como visual mas que é um
grande mestre que eu tenho a gente
precisa se livrar da nossa ignorância é
aprendida e porque isso é importante
por algum motivo a esse motivo é
biológico seres humanos a gente
cruzo a necessidade de sobreviver
biologicamente com a necessidade de se
conectar a gente é um dos poucos a seres
ou é o único ser que depende que quando
quando recém nascido mas ele depende em
mais um bom tempo até ele ficar até
ficar independente portanto a
sobrevivência conexão fazem parte
intrínseca da forma como a gente
experimenta a realidade é quando a gente
viu a foto da da natália que a foto da
natália recém nascida
todo mundo se emociona porque o
recém-nascido ele traz ao mesmo tempo a
beleza de ser potencial puro uma
recém-nascida potencial com a
dependência ea gente começa a formar as
respostas que a gente vai dar pra
realidade nesse ambiente aliás está
falando de neurociência neurobiologia
tem pesquisas impressionantes que formam
e uma outra que estava além do outro dia
neurobiologia que disse que o estado
emocional da mãe nos últimos três meses
de gravidez quando a criança está com
seis meses o sistema neurológico dela já
está mais informado o estado emocional
da mãe trouxe uma mãe que trabalha muito
tem muito stress fica muito nervosa vai
afetar para o resto da vida aquela
criança forma como ela interpreta a
realidade que atende a chorar mais e
tende a se ativar mais têm de ter
sistema nervoso mais ativado
portanto quando a criança tem é recém
nascido como é que ela experimenta a
realidade
a natália e um bebezinho italy
experimenta realidade muito diferente da
forma com a gente experimenta realidade
a criança está em totalidade em
diferenciada com uma mala michael dizia
ela tem fusão com o meio físico ela o
peito da mãe dela em um cobertor não tem
diferença deve ser um grande barato é
todo mundo já deve ter uma experiência
de fluxo aqui fazendo alguma coisa essa
experiência de integração
um recém nascido tem essa experiência 24
horas por dia sete dias por semana e
portanto nesse momento e foi bonito
quando quando trouxeram que a
experiência da natália ela falou isso
algumas vezes a gente vem com esse
mandato de seu amor
eu sou o amor é preciso fazer nada para
ser amado sua expressão de amor porque
eu tenho conexão com tudo agora para
sobreviver
a criança começa a reagir é essa fusão
emocional não sei se vocês se todo mundo
vai perceber mas já existe uma diferença
grande entre a natália recém-nascida
natália de nove meses atrás de nove
meses eu estava sentada em um evento
importante que acontece com o recém
nascido quando a criança faz seis meses
ela senta essa substância fisicamente
ela percebe que ela mãe o meio são
diferentes fisicamente e é o rosto da
natália ou a expressão corporal da
natália já era muito diferente de quando
era recém nascida ela já como já
aconteceu muita coisa importante é
natália foi aprendendo que quando ela
tinha fome ela chorar se ela é
segmentada quando ela estava
desconfortável porque ela tinha feito as
necessidades dela ela chorava a lei a
ser trocada
quando ela tinha dor ela era atendida é
ser trocada todos nós tivemos esses
traumas de desenvolvimento ao longo da
nossa vida
além dos traumas mais impressionantes
traumas de choques nos que no que nos
impactaram alguns de nós mais alguns de
nós mesmos o mais importante é que
apesar de estar de desfazer fusão física
a criança tem fusão emocional com a mãe
até os dois anos de idade
e aí o mandato que era eu sou o amor
passa seu mandato eu sou amado
condicionalmente a criança passa a
sentir que ela só é amada
sob certas condições aquela pessoa que
mais amarelo
é também aqui acaba em fingindo dor e
fingindo reações porque a gente constrói
no nosso sistema nervoso e no nosso
processo reações baseadas em
necessidades atendidas e não atendidas
todo mundo que está aqui deve ser como
eu neurótico normal
significa que teve mais necessidades
atendidas do que necessidades não
atendidas mas todos nós tivemos
necessidades não atendidas
o padrão de repetição dessas
necessidades não atendidas a crianças a
partir dos seus 23 anos quem tem filho
pequeno crianças com dois anos e meio
três anos começa a articular e falar em
primeira pessoa
ela começa a desenvolver que a
psicologia chama do ego ou personalidade
mas o senso de identidade o censo o
censo deu em mais ou menos algumas
abordagens da psicologia de
desenvolvimento levam isso pra criança
com 6 7 8 9 10 11 anos dizem que até 7
você formou script
então você e eu sou o amor eu sou amado
condicionalmente agora eu me amo
incondicionalmente
nesse momento a gente desenvolver o
nosso script e o script e é o script
para ser chamado para ser reconhecido eu
vou ser perfeccionista
eu vou ser vítimas eu ficar doente chama
atenção
eu vou fazer as coisas é preciso estar
sempre em atividade porque é assim que
eu sou reconhecido cada um de nós
escolher um script e aquela
possibilidade o potencial todo dia eu
sou o amor colapsa um escrito
pior do que colapsaram script a gente
desenvolve o superego
que fica chicoteando a gente falando é
bom o suficiente você não está fazendo o
suficiente a gente passa a se amar
incondicionalmente eu só me sinto pleno
se eu tiver fazendo alguma coisa somente
cinco pleno se eu tirar 10 só me sinto
plena certas condições forem forem
aparecer então qual é a e aí a realidade
tudo que emerge na nossa frente a gente
vai com esse óculos o que a gente vai
fazer a gente vai passar a atrair
pessoas e situações que não vão nos dar
o que os nossos pais nos deram
vou falar de novo a gente vai passar
atrair pessoas e situações que não vamos
dar o que a gente não teve porque apesar
de dolorido é lar doce lar
é o que a gente conhece
eu tava eu vi outro dia uma foto minha
de 9 anos quando fiz a primeira comunhão
nasci numa família superou meio de são
paulo
fui criado como católico foi até
coroinha e também adorava esporte
futebol competição o meu meu script foi
script dodô fazer a minha intensidade em
fazer muitas coisas para ser visto para
ser amado e chama a atenção uma coisa
foi a que eu fiz primeira comunhão com
nove anos eu estava segurando uma vela
assim e olhava com olhar triste pra
esquerda naquele momento em quando tinha
nove anos mais ou menos um ano antes
quando eu tinha de oito para nove anos
nessa mesma época eu lembrei por isso
que essa foto me chama atenção
eu fui durante um tempo assediado por um
adolescente de 13 anos mais velho que eu
me impactou profundamente imaginam como
impactou meio script a minha história
porque era uma pessoa que gostava um
adolescente que eu idealizava e de
repente eu tinha que lidar com a minha
mãe descobriu lidar com a culpa é mesmo
tempo com a sensação todas as confusões
essa história de fazer ganhou uma outra
perspectiva uma outra proporção que
a ver agora tinha que ir além de fazer
coisas eu tinha que provar que eu era
homem o tempo naquela época tinha pavor
o pavor absurdo de ser gay então tinha
que provar isso dentro ficou
completamente a minha relação com as
mulheres as minhas relações afetivas a
minha relação com o mundo tive que só
focar minha sensibilidade porque
sensível era feio e foi esse script que
eu que eu desenvolvi e na realidade é
isso que a gente faz quando a gente
desenvolve script
a gente vai pra nossa relação com a
família a gente vai tentar mostrar para
os nossos familiares que a gente vai ser
o que eles gostariam que aqueles que a
gente que a gente fosse ou o contrário
que dá na mesma
quando a gente vai compra a gente só
está tentando chamado do mesmo jeito
quando me revelo e você completamente
oposto
a gente só tem ainda um outro caminho a
gente vai encontrar um grupo de amigos
que não é um grupo de amigos que vai ter
de suportar mais um grupo de amigos onde
você vai poder exercer esse script e se
você não exerce scripts e sofre até
bullying
a gente vai é encontrar um grupo de
gente vai trabalhar para reforçar essa
idéia do nosso script ea gente só por
isso que o ambiente organizacional as
pessoas sofrem com o trabalho porque
elas sofrem cada vez mais porque elas
não são vistas e elas não são
reconhecidas jeito que elas gostariam
porque no trabalho têm sucesso em
fracasso mas a gente só aceita o sucesso
e mais a gente vai buscar
relacionamentos afetivos com as pessoas
que vão apertar mais o nosso botão e
vamos deixar cada vez mais sentindo o
nosso script do jeito é impressionante
como a gente vai atrair alguém que
efetivamente não vai dar e essa pessoa
sabe exatamente como nos nos irritarmos
e sofrer por isso que os casamentos são
bastante sofrido
qual é o movimento que a gente pode
fazer então que muda tudo mas que muda
tudo mas não muda nada
o primeiro movimento importante para
fazer dar um passo para trás
reconhecer que o que está acontecendo
agora é o dia 10 de junho de 2017 às 18
horas em alguma coisa e é a primeira vez
que tem o dia do dia 10 de junho de 2017
não vai ter outro
como é que eu consigo olhar para a
realidade como o momento refrescado e dá
espaço para trás sem deixar que o meu
sistema nervoso do bofa realidade para
que assim a gente possa escolher se
conectar com cada um cada uma dessas
dimensões de um jeito diferente queria
compartilhar uma história porque alguns
de vocês sabe eu falei meu técnico minha
filha morava aqui em porto alegre
minha filha acabou fazendo ciências
sociais na ufrgs se engajou no monte de
movimento social resolveu viver sem
dinheiro e eo namorado dela veio de
corda ou de bicicleta para porto alegre
e eles resolveram sair de bicicleta pelo
brasil se imagina como é que quando o
sistema nervoso e eu tive que fazer
muito porque essa idéia do sistema
nervoso não é que uma vez que você sabe
isso acabou resolvido ali acontece
momento um momento em que o sistema
nervoso um software programado pra
sentir o meu desespero de acontecer
alguma coisa com a minha filha a minha
sensação de pai culpado porque eu me
separei quando ainda tinha 10 anos e que
parte das escolhas dela tinha a ver com
tudo o que tinha acontecido
foi super duro até conseguir dar esse
passo para trás
eu pensei o seguinte se fosse a filha de
um amigo meu falando olha a minha filha
está querendo se engajar em projeto
social ea nanda agora tá super envolvida
na recuperação do rio doce está em
regência se formou em yoga e continua de
bicicleta sem dinheiro com as trocas
mais simples
eu falei eu ia adorar que um amigo que a
filha de um amigo meu tivesse mas porque
não estão aceitando e quando chegou de
porto alegre e são paulo de bicicleta
resolver entrar no mundo dela falou 'pai
o mundo não é perigoso
o mundo generoso e eu resolvi aí quando
a gente foi de são paulo a ubatuba são
350 kms eu fui de bicicleta conan e eu
tive o presente de de entrar no mundo
dela pelo olhar dela e me surpreendi
todo todo todo dia que a gente chegava
numa cidade
alguém falava
porque legal pai filha pedalando fique
em casa dorme em casa se não têm comer a
generosidade das pessoas a partir do
olhar generoso dela mudou completamente
a minha perspectiva me fez eu me
aproximar da minha filha de jeito
completamente novo que eu tenho muito
privilégio de ver como é que eu tenho
amizade com banana
então eu querendo dar um exemplo quer
dizer que eu sou melhor nem pior que
ninguém mais e se essa possibilidade de
dar um passo para trás e ver o que está
emergindo e falar eu tô reproduzido
passado eu estou enxergando o presente
como um presente para que a partir disso
a relação com a família não seja mais
uma relação de agradável de preencher
expectativa mas honrasse centralidade
ana que está aqui
a mãe dela faleceu há pouco como é que é
nó pode sentir a mãe dela nas costas das
costas dela e todas as mulheres centenas
milhares e seu melhor que ela pode ser
agora é assim que a gente honra à nossa
família não é agradando a nossa família
mas sendo que a gente veio para ser
honrado a nossa centralidade
como é que a gente cria um grupo de
amigos que nenhum de nós que na visão
indiana é uma sanga como é que encontra
uma sanga uma comunidade onde o descanso
onde um após o outro
como é que olha para o trabalho
sustentando o paradoxo do propósito de
estar a serviço sem esperar que nada
grandioso contexto e como é que eu olho
para a relação de intimidade na relação
afetiva como um container poderoso e
frágil que precisa ser nutrido todo dia
onde um da permissão para o outro para
suportar desafio ao outro para a
evolução de cada um ea evolução do casal
pra mim esse é o presente da vida como é
que a gente pode olhar momento o momento
sendo um pincel sendo um instrumento que
produz arte momento a momento olhando
para a realidade como ela emerge com uma
tela em branco
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]